Robert Orlean, and his partner in crime, John
Streep, zipped through the murky waters of
the Louisiana Bayou on a speedboat.
These men were dealers in the illicit, but
their specialty was not any kind of contraband
you’d probably recognize: Orlean and Streep
dealt in rare orchids, illegally poached from
areas where they’re considered endangered,
and sold to high-paying rare plant collectors.
As any seller or collector knows, rarity is
the hallmark of value, and what these two
men would encounter in the swamp that day
was truly one of a kind.
The problem for this pair of greedy opportunists
is that only one of them would live to tell
the tale, and thanks to the SCP Foundation,
the other wouldn’t remember it for long.
That’s what happens when you have a dangerous
run-in with a certain mean, green, swamp-dwelling
creature that doesn’t take kindly to unwanted
visitors.
And no, we’re not talking about a crocodile.
Orlean and Streep continued through the swamp,
keeping their keen eyes out for the flash
of light blue that’d give away the orchids
they were seeking.
Little did they know, from the murky darkness
between the reeds, a pair of big, yellow eyes
were watching them back.
They were intruders in a stranger’s land.
Threats, just like the Bad Man.
They would need to be dealt with accordingly,
or a grim history would repeat itself.
The boat came to a halt, as the two poachers
finally saw one of the rare flowers they were
looking for, arising out of the muck.
Orlean leaped from the boat and began wading
towards his prize.
The flower would fetch him and his partner
a pretty penny if they could get it back in
good condition.
The motions were so well-practiced for Orlean,
so automatic, that he didn’t even notice
something was moving through the waters towards
him.
Gators and snakes were an occupational hazard
for people like Orlean - he kept a revolver
holstered just below his shoulder as a precaution
- but the thing about to kill him was unlike
anything he’d ever faced before.
Just as his careful fingers curled around
the orchid’s stem, Orlean heard Streep screaming
from the boat.
He was frantically pointing at something just
beyond Orlean, emerging from the reeds.
Orlean turned and felt his jaw falling open
in horror at the sight of it.
At first, it seemed almost like a waterlogged
corpse.
Thick, matted black hair, heavy with grease
and muddy bog water, teeming with parasitic
swamp-life.
Her skin was green and bumpy, like that of
a toad, dripping with viscous, green sweat
that seemed like it could only be the by-product
of rot.
But those eyes, those big, yellow amphibian
eyes, they were alive as they were inhuman.
This creature wasn’t a corpse, it was something
else entirely.
Her body cleared the water, standing at Orlean’s
height now and facing him, eye to eye.
She was naked, her dignity preserved by her
long tangle of hair.
Her body was human-shaped, except for her
freakishly long, thin limbs.
Her belly appeared visibly bloated or engorged,
like a woman in the mid-stages of pregnancy.
Orlean had never smelled something so foul
in his entire life, which was mostly spent
wading through swamps and bogs.
She smelled like death itself.
Streep was screaming for Orlean to climb back
into the boat, but Orlean knew it was already
too late.
He reached for his holstered pistol, but before
he could clear leather, the creature let out
a horrific, guttural hawking noise, and spewed
a stream of black goo onto Orlean’s face.
It was hot, sticky, and foul-tasting, like
a kind of tar rendered from corpses.
It plastered his open mouth and nose shut,
and began to suffocate him.
He tried desperately to claw at his face and
tear the offending substance away, but all
that succeeded in doing was getting his fingers
stuck.
While Orlean suffocated and Streep screamed
terrified obscenities from the boat, the creature
just watched and smiled through rotten teeth.
It was nice to see them panic, just like the
Bad Man who’d come before.
They were in the wrong.
They deserved this.
Orlean soon realized that nothing he could
do would save himself.
He’d spent his life in a dangerous profession,
and been lucky until now, but the reaper catches
up with everyone eventually.
The last thing he saw as the world went black
was this creature - this Swamp Woman - wading
towards him through the water with a hungry
look in her eye.
She grabbed him on either side of his face,
and just held him there.
What was that sound?
Was it fizzling?
Like something was burning, or even melting?
She just kept staring and smiling with those
awful rotten teeth.
Robert Orlean went to sleep in her hands and
never woke up.
Back on the boat, a desperate John Streep
was watching a scene that - if it wasn’t
for the later intervention of the SCP Foundation
- would haunt him until his dying day.
He watched his partner undergo a process that
was somewhere between rotting and melting.
He withered away in the Swamp Woman’s hands,
degrading into thick, black sludge that she
drank through her thirsty skin.
As much as it pained him to leave his friend
behind, Streep knew that there was no saving
him now.
All he could possibly do was escape with his
own life.
He pulled the ripcord on the boat’s motor,
and tore his way back to the nearest township,
the shape of the nightmarish Swamp Woman shrinking
in the distance behind him.
When he ran into the local police station,
half-mad with grief and fear, screaming about
the monster that killed his friend in the
swamp, the police understandably detained
him for further questioning.
When his criminal history as a poacher was
flagged up on the database, it became clear
he probably wasn’t leaving for a while.
That’s when a Foundation agent embedded
in the department passed a memo about the
case’s strangeness up the chain of command,
and a covert Mobile Task Force was soon dispatched
to the swamp in order to locate and capture
the anomalous creature that Streep had claimed
took his friend’s life..
After a few days of searching, the Swamp Woman
was captured by the Foundation and redesignated
as SCP-811, before being delivered back to
a nearby containment site.
Luckily for Foundation disinformation agents,
the cover story was practically gift-wrapped
for them on this one: It had been a dispute
between two hardcore criminals, and as the
saying goes, there’s no honor among thieves.
Streep had murdered Orlean over a pay cut
dispute, and thrown him into the swamp, where
his body was eaten by gators.
A few falsified records and implanted memories
later, and the Foundation was free to do what
it pleased with SCP-811.
But the Swamp Woman would prove to be full
of surprises and contradictions.
While designated Euclid, the containment procedures
for the creature were rather extensive - for
its own benefit.
Like a lot of creatures who’d never existed
in captivity before, it had very specific
needs in terms of its artificial habitat - the
Foundation needed to be on top of everything
from the pH levels of its soil acidity to
the optimal temperatures and humidity levels
of its containment chamber, built to resemble
the creature’s natural swamp habitat.
The Swamp Woman is mostly non-aggressive to
Foundation staff, but certain precautions
need to be taken in order to ensure everyone’s
safety around her.
While she’s largely humanoid, her internal
physiology vastly differs from that of humans.
Her veins and digestive system are non-functional.
She consumes her prey by melting it into black
sludge with the highly caustic secretions
of her skin, before absorbing it back through
her pores.
The waste material collects in her stomach,
which she then expels voluntarily through
an action similar to vomiting.
This is often used defensively, or in hunting
prey, as the unfortunate Robert Orlean found
out.
As a result, people working in 811’s containment
chamber need to do so in pairs and wear heavily
sealed hazmat suits for obvious safety reasons.
The creature also proved to be surprisingly
intelligent.
While not a genius by any means, it was no
mere mindless animal: the Swamp Woman had
an intellect and communication skills on par
with your average feral child, though one
that had been brought up and socialized in
a relatively normal home before being turned
loose and experiencing a decline in its mental
and social development.
Her words have a childlike construction to
them, as though English isn’t her native
language, and she’s still in the very early
stages of learning it.
She gave herself a name, “Aé”, and began
to cooperate well with Foundation staff, in
exchange for having her needs met.
Since being brought into containment, she’s
made a number of requests: These included
some requests that had been denied by the
Foundation, such as the regular provision
of bovine prey for its chamber and a variety
of fish from its native environment to make
it feel more at home.
However, there are some requests that the
Foundation has approved, like a wooden hairbrush,
and a D-Class in a hazmat suit entering the
room daily in order to help wash her hair,
often bogged down by the frequency at which
her skin produces thick, caustic oils.
In one particularly strange request, she asked
for a turtle in a hazmat suit to act as a
companion in her containment chamber, as she
reacted negatively to the idea of having turtles
as food.
Sadly, this was one of the denied requests.
SCP-811 was also involved in a few cross-tests
with other anomalies, leading to curious results.
After realizing just how dangerous SCP-811’s
secretions could be, Foundation researchers
naturally floated the idea of using it on
SCP-682, in its seemingly endless termination
experiments.
A sample of 682’s flesh was successfully
decayed by the dangerous mucus, so a larger
quantity, collected over a number of months,
was then sprayed all over the beast.
It managed to reduce 682’s body mass by
27%, melting its way through the covered flesh
down to the bone.
However, at that point, it was unable to decay
further, and SCP-682 soon returned back to
its normal state.
Who could have possibly seen that coming,
right?
However, a much more interesting and enlightening
cross-test occurred with SCP-978, the Desire
Camera.
If you haven’t already seen our video on
the Desire Camera, it’s pretty much exactly
what the name suggests: A polaroid camera
that reveals the deepest desire of its subject,
and the Foundation decided to test it on a
large number of staff and anomalies - one
of those being SCP-811.
When a photograph was taken of SCP-811 just
staring at the camera, the resulting photo
depicted a human woman with the same height,
build, and facial features as SCP-811, braiding
yellow ribbons into her hair and wearing a
blue sundress.
The attending researchers felt this raised
an interesting question: Were they looking
at an aspiration towards humanity from SCP-811,
or was this a yearning to return to what had
been before?
There was only one way to find out: Conduct
an interview with the creature herself.
When the interview began, the researchers
pressed 811 on some of her earliest memories.
One of the key details she shared was regarding
a mysterious man whom she claimed came to
her before she looked like she did now.
Back when her skin was soft and pink.
The Bad Man.
He injected something into her arm, and whatever
it was, it changed her.
Mutated her.
Took away her precious humanity.
The first thing she remembered feeling after
that was an all-consuming hunger, and then
melting and devouring the one who changed
her.
Destroying any possible answers as to who
he was or why he did it in the process.
It was a story of victimization and dehumanization
so cruel and upsetting that Researcher Wachtel,
an assistant researcher attending the interview,
actually threw up - later debriefing interviews
revealed it was because he had a daughter
of roughly the same age, with long, dark hair.
If SCP-811 has any parents herself, we may
never know.
Such is the strange tragedy of SCP-811, whether
you wish to call her by her number, a nickname
like the Swamp Woman, or her self-given name
of Aé.
We’ll likely never know who she was before,
as not even she knows now.
It’s an unsettling reminder that all of
our grasps on humanity are looser than you
think.
Sometimes, all it takes is one chance encounter
to change who you are completely...
Now go check out “SCP-2845 - Alien God Crash
Lands on Earth - THE DEER” and “Minecraft
World Destroyer SCP-4335 - A Welt In The Crucible”
for more fascinating anomalous creatures!